let's take a moment to remember because
we've been looking at simultaneous
equations I should say you've been
looking in simonsaiz equations quite a
bit over the last couple of weeks and
you've actually sort of developed a bit
of a suite of skills and techniques that
you can use when you see a pair of
equations and you know you're gonna have
to solve them simultaneously because
there's two Medus so can you see for
example if I hit the second line here
right and I just gave you 2x plus 3y
equals five um you can't find just one
solution to that why is that do you know
but why you can't find just one solution
to a question like that okay so there's
two there's two pointy rows right
there's two things that you couldn't
solve for um but the point was like I
can change the value of x and that will
give me a different value of Y right and
each time you change you get any value
that can and it's set of values and
that's kind of well what which ones this
solution and at that point they all are
right so once you add in a second one
you're like oh now I have more
information I can put these together I
can solve them all the points I saw -
okay yeah so I want you remember what
was the very first thing we did we've
got a pair of equations like this how
could we find a solution for this okay
so yeah we can we can actually label
these now before we got to lately I will
I mean use these labels in a second but
there was an approach we met very early
on that didn't really require us to
label them did you have to draw some
things though did you remember okay so
our second method was to solve things
graphically so what we did was we said
actually we can represent these guys are
straight lines if you draw these
straight lines the solution is where the
straight lines intersect where they meet
do you remember that okay so in other
words where are the lines at the same
place where are they simultaneously
that's one of the ways you do it on the
precursor to do it graphically is
yeah table village but we kind of
decided for each of these the even
though they worked number one main kind
of only work some of the time like this
one you had to pick like the right
values to get there and you maybe just
chose bad delis the first time you don't
want to have a table that grows forever
and what was our um what was our
elasticity users a graphical method why
didn't we like it it's very time
consuming right
and it's also less precise if it's not
bang on like you've got your grid on
your book but if the point where they
meet isn't like on a grid line you know
I don't know it's kind of around there
so it lacks precision
that's why we introduced on the third
method this week which was not good so
if you solve by substitution you don't
need a table you don't need a picture
you deal with these guys just as X's and
Y's now once you get in precision and
speed because it is fast you don't have
to draw it is more precise can you have
to rely on a drawing that might be
inaccurate what she sacrifice is that
it's just kind of harder to wrap your
head around right like you're just
moving these abstract X's and Y's but I
think we all agreed that for most cases
it's a worthy trade-off okay now
elimination is the fourth member
elimination it's the fourth one and it's
kind of like a parallel for substitution
even better
it's like substation it's purely
algebraic you don't have to draw
anything you just have to muck around
with these X's and Y's in a particular
way and that will leave your solution
okay so here's the idea and if you got
another color there it might be helpful
what you want to look at is the wing we
did substitution in fact don't write
this down but just remember if I give
you an equation like this
here we go so if you had a look at this
can you tell me if we use method three
if we did solve a substitution if I call
this equation one and equation two what
would be your next line I'm going to sum
one of these into the other two which
one do I subject equation two into one
very good because you can see this one
already has one of the pretty rules as
the subject right so it makes that easy
to put into this see this up two into
one and the line you would get out of
result as a result would look like this
what do you think you were great okay
now here's the really important thing I
want you to look really carefully at
this line the reason why this line is an
improvement on the original situation is
that from the beginning you had two
letters you had to printing routes and
you liked either them you got two
letters here as well but this black line
here that a circle it's just got one
right and we've been solving these for
years actually and so even though it
takes into practice you can expand this
you can collect like terms we're fine
with that
okay so you turn a problem with two
printables into a problem with one and
that's better
so other words if you look a problem and
you can remove one of the letters from
problem in other words if you can
eliminate wonderful letters out of the
problem then that instantly makes the
problem easier to solve okay so have a
look at this now here's the way I'm
suggesting we do this and at the first
point it might be a bit confusing as to
why I'm doing it but it will become
apparent I want these two pairs of
letters here I want some of them to
match with each other okay so here's
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna take the
second equation I'm going to multiply it
by two okay now like I said can you
might be wondering why that why - why
not three why equation two not equation
one in a second hopefully you'll be able
to tell me why equation 2 times 2 means
everything you see there left-hand side
but the right-hand side multiply
everything by 2 if you multiply the
left-hand side by 2 what do you get
okay there's the left-hand side and he
comes the right-hand side you with me so
far
okay now what I've done is I've mucked
about with equation two I've created a
third equation but do you remember I
suggest rather than calling this crater
three I would probably call that today
yeah you call it anything you like but
at least this basically where it came
from
now what should you compare this
equation with just name with the very
first equation than one which we left
alone okay do you see that each of them
has a two excellent
all right so these two because these
bits are equal right if I call add them
in the right way the two x's can cancel
each other out and they will become
eliminated from the problem all I'll be
left with is wise and that's what we did
here we turned a two pronumeral problem
into a wonder printable problem and that
was better so the question becomes well
in what way do I put these guys together
so the two X's will cancel each other
out what do you reckon
yeah very good I should do some kind of
subtraction right because then there are
me a 2x takeaway in 2x and that'll be
left with nothing it would be eliminated
okay now as to which way you do it it
actually doesn't matter he will get the
same result by the way but in this case
I'm thinking we go with me to don't have
this in your book so we don't really I
don't thinking our next step will be
equation one takeaway equation to that
all right so let's all write that down